so you're probably wondering what
happened to all my videos so yesterday I
spoke to a copyright lawyer just off the
wind just kind of tracking things
through their life through my videos I
had been concerned for a couple weeks
now if my videos may be you know not
copyright friendly not fit the terms of
fair use I was curious so I talked to
this lawyer and we went through my
videos and the process of how I might
make them I showed him a couple of the
videos and it turns out that about 95%
of my videos were not in fact copyright
friendly and did not fit the terms of
fair use this is my fault
I was not following the rules properly
and as a consequence I had to get rid of
the videos back when I made the channel
years ago I got into a very bad habit of
you know oh I need a picture of a flask
go to Google that picture looks great
I'll take that picture put in the video
looks awesome and I guess just doing
that is not it's not kosher
relative to fair use and copyright you
know and I was doing that and that's
wrong and you can't do that so if you're
making videos on YouTube let this be a
warning don't don't do that I I did that
and my library videos I worked so hard
on for many years is gone
it sucks I'm not happy but it's it's
it's a necessary precaution now what
does this mean for questions for science
am i quitting YouTube no this is a major
setback but it's not the end on yes I
don't have my videos I have like four
videos you can watch those if you want
but this is not the end it's just hiccup
and the timeline of questions for
science it's going nowhere in fact I
should have a new video a new video out
next week we can have
and I'll continue my same format it's
just that these videos are now gone and
I'm sorry I was not doing it right and
these are the consequences but right now
I need your support more than ever to
stay with the channel to watch the
videos to like share the stuff you know
the whole spiel but now's the time that
it counts the most and I ask you to
please stay and to continue watching
again this is just a small hiccup in a
year from now it's gonna be nothing so
thanks for watching and stay tuned oh
it's all I could say thank you